- Un reporter de la télévision
d'État iranienne montre
dans la prison d'Evine.
paisiblement.
les dégles dégles dégles dégles.
Un important incendie s'est
déclaré l y a eu des affrontemes
aussi, au moins quatre détenus
ts, une soixantaine
ont été blessés.
La République islamique d'Iran
entre leentre leentre leentre l.
L'évènement coïncide avec une
autre journée de protestations
pour dénoncer la mort de
la jeune Iraniennen mois. Den ms
de personnes arrêtées dans
les manifestations auraient été
envoyées dans cette prison.
L'endroit est tristement
célèbre, car pluues y sont
détenus.
- Zahra Kazemi a été battue
en Iran.- Il y a presque 20 ans,
la photojournaliste irano-canadt
morte des suites de mauvais
traitements à la prison d'Evine
des familles de prisonniers.
La Montréalaise deéalaise deéals
a été battue, agressée
sexuellement et torturée.ident n
Ebrahim Raissi a accusé
Joe Biden d'avoir provoqué
le chaos dans son pays.
Le président des États-Unis
de Téhéran dans la rue
pour plus de liberainsi que
plusieurs ONG s'inquiètent
tuation datuation datuation datn
d'Evine; des prisonniers
étrangers y sont encore détenus.
anada, Montréal.